hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
early on in politics book 1 Aristotle
provides a long discussion of what it
means for human beings to be what he
calls political or social animals that
is animals whose very nature is to be
connected with others of their own kind
in ways that go beyond the herd or in
the case of other social and political
animals the Beehive or the termite
colony things like that we are political
and social animals in a somewhat
different way and one of the sub
discussions of that focuses on a very
important distinction between us and the
other animals it has to do with the
nature of communication and the
implications for the type and range of
communication that we are capable of by
opposition to other animals that do
communicate with each other but don't
communicate quite the same things or in
the same ways or to the same degree so
why are we social animals Aristotle says
that it has to do with our possession of
logos logos is a term that means a lot
of different things in Greek and it
means more than one thing even for
Aristotle but among the main meanings
that Aristotle has in mind that are
particularly important here in this
discussion one of them is speech if you
like you can also translate it as
language or discourse it's got a very
broad sense to it
it also means reason that is the the
sense of rational faculty the our
ability to make sense out of things and
these are intimately connected for
Aristotle we have reason in part because
we have the capacity for communication
but we also have something to
communicate about and we communicate in
the distinct
ways that we do because we are reasoning
beings so what about all their animals
he tells us that other animals which you
know we have most of our nature in
common with they do in fact possess what
he calls voice and he he makes a
distinction here between being able to
make a sound phone a or we might think
of communicating in other ways you know
bees communicate through pheromones
through their dances we could extend
this very far but they have a form of
communication that is at least in
relation to us not as extensive in
relation to their own natures it's
perfectly fine it communicates what they
need to know about what they need to
communicate about bees communicate about
where to find the nectar or you know
that we need alert Hornets are invading
let's let's get out here and start
stinging them or any sorts of other
things that they might communicate
horses communicate with each other all
sorts of animals have voice Aristotle
says that this permits them to grasp
what for human beings are going to be
what we can call a certain kind of moral
quality moral not necessarily in the
sense of dealing with morality and
ethics but dealing with a much broader
sense of good and bad values what is it
that animals can actually perceive
pleasure and pain Aristotle is
crystal-clear about this when you do
something that hurts an animal it really
does hurt them they may not hurt them in
exactly the same way as it does a human
being thinking about insects or fish you
know they may not feel pain to the
extent that an animal the more higher
developed nervous system does but it is
pain and they also feel pleasure they
enjoy things grasshoppers presumably
enjoy eating grass or whatever else it
is that they eat spiders presumably
enjoy crawling around
you know seeing a thing that they can
jump on and attack if they're jumping
spider or they they're sitting in their
web they enjoy sitting in their web
feeling the vibration of the prey and
eating it up
they probably enjoy mating as well you
can well imagine so animals can perceive
and they can also communicate to each
other this is very important they're not
just locked in their own private worlds
they can communicate to each other pain
and pleasure or more generally the
painful and the pleasurable so when for
example a bird you know cries a certain
way and another bird comes by because it
realizes that now there's something that
they can both eat and enjoy that would
be an example of this when animals are
engaging with each other and showing
affection that might be understood in
the same way human beings go far beyond
this according to Aristotle so he says
the mere voice can indicate pain and
pleasure it's possessed by other animals
as well their nature has been developed
so far as to have sensation perception
of what is painful and pleasant and to
signify these to each other but speech
logos is designed to indicate other
things what are those other things that
speech indicates Aristotle is not
attempting to provide you here with a
comprehensive list because he actually
uses kite Allah in the Greek which is
the Greek equivalent of etc in English
it means and all the others right he's
just giving us a few prime examples here
and we need to also supply one very
important one as we go on with this
discussion but what are these moral
values
she says logos speech reason however we
want to translate it is set up in such a
way that it allows us to indicate to
each other to talk about to name to
distinguish the useful some federal
and the harmful notice that these are
opposites to each other just as pain and
pleasure were right all of these things
that we're signifying are in fact
opposed qualities and we can talk about
things in between as well something
that's partly useful and partly harmful
or neither harmful nor useful all of
those are possibilities for us we can
communicate these to each other the just
or the right toady kion and the unjust
to Adi cone the wrong another key one is
the good in a very general sense to
Agathon and the bad till cocoon we could
think of other synonyms for this as well
and then Aristotle says quite famously
in this passage and all the others so
what would all those others include well
at the very least they would include
another one that Aristotle and Plato
both include in their list of moral
qualities whenever they're talking about
these sorts of things and one of these
is the Cologne which here I've
translated as fear but also could be
translated as Noble also could be
translated as beautiful also could be
translated as intrinsically attractive
and then the foul the ice crone which
can also be translated as the ugly can
also be translated as the shameful or
the base there's a number of different
ways in which we can talk about that we
the Greeks had one single term that they
preferred to use or set of terms and we
have a much larger vocabulary in that
way all of these things all of these
binary opposition's and the spectrums
within and the distinctions that are
possible are things that we can signify
to each other through language there are
also things that we can think about by
using logos as well aristotle goes even
further
here he doesn't just talk about us
conceiving of these and then talking
about them he says that we perceive them
we have ice thesis which is the same
term that is used for perceiving through
the senses other things like tasting the
bitterness of the coffee or hearing the
beautiful music beautiful being Cologne
right so we have on a very basic level
because we are rational or communicative
animals a capacity for a much greater
range of differentiation of moral
qualities of values than do the other
animals we also do perceive the painful
and the pleasurable when we put all of
these together we have a lot that we can
talk about Aristotle goes a little bit
further he says in this passage that it
is agreement or community in these
values that constitutes human community
so it's not just for example agreeing
that there is a just and an unjust
it's agreeing what the just and the
unjust are that helps to bind us
together that expresses this essence of
ourselves as social animals here in this
passage he talks about the the agreement
or the community the Koinonia in these
matters but another implication that we
ought to consider that is not discussed
right here but is quite important and
plays a role in Aristotle's rhetoric is
that these very moral values are not
only the things that we can find
ourselves in agreement about and be
connected with each other through they
are also the things that we can disagree
about that we can argue about that we
can find ourselves in conflict about
that we may wish to and this is where
the rhetoric comes in make a case about
trying to convince somebody that
something really is useful like a policy
or that somebody really
is unjust as in a criminal case or that
something really is noble as in what we
call epideictic rhetoric so all of these
things are involved in human beings
being social animals there may be some
exceptions people who cannot readily
perceive the right and the wrong or the
fair and the foul it may take a lot of
work to get our conceptions of these on
the right track so we're not just
naively reacting but that comes from a
basis of being able to perceive and
communicate with others about these
fundamental moral qualities that
Aristotle takes to be a central aspect
of human nature that builds upon our
animality and takes it through logos
much further
you